So we just got some feedback
from Jeremy about our app.
One of the things I wanted you to note
about this is that he didn't have
trouble with some of the things that we
had trouble with in the first iteration
of user feedback.
He had no trouble
finding the check boxes.
There wasn't any confusion
around task versus event.
And he seemed able to navigate
around the app pretty well.
However, there were a couple of things
that we noticed were a little bit wrong
with the app still.
Jeremy wanted to actually
input his data into the app.
And Jeremy noticed there were
a lot of extra things in the app,
that maybe weren't tied to the core
aspects that I was asking him about.
These are things that we'll
look into in the future and
as we continue to iterate
are things that you would solve.